das übersetzen auf der fähre ist immer
wie ein kurzes innehalten wie kurze
pausen von der hektik und dem lärm der
16 millionen metropole istanbul eine
junge frau in blauer uniform wirft die
taue zum anlegen aus es ist eine kleine
revolution
eine weibliche revolution bei der
städtischen fährlinie
[Musik]
seit meiner kindheit liebe ich das meer
ich wollte immer schon kapitänin werden
und ich tue alles um ihr diesen traum zu
erfüllen
dilara ist erst 20 jahre alt hat bereits
einen autischer ausbildung abgeschlossen
fuhr auf handelsschiffen
dann sah sie im vergangenen jahr die
stellenanzeige der stadt istanbul bewarb
sich und wurde zusammen mit vier anderen
frauen angenommen
ich habe mich beworben und sie haben
nicht tatsächlich zum bewerbungsgespräch
eingeladen
ich war einen monat so aufgeregt das
kann ich gar nicht beschreiben
ich hatte gespräche mit verschiedenen
direktorin schließlich wurden wir als
kapitäns anwärterin eingestellt was
könnte die größte chance für uns sein
seit vielen jahren gibt es auf den
schiffen fast keine frauen mehr
deshalb bin ich stolz hier als eine der
ersten frauen arbeiten zu können
[Musik]
der traum kapitänen zu werden ist das
eine die realität in einer männerwelt
das anders
[Musik]
am anfang gab es schon leute die sich
umgedreht und uns schräg angeschaut
haben manche haben uns sogar gesagt was
machst du hier gehe und mache eine
ausbildung als krankenschwester oder als
lehrerin
es gab starke vorurteile ging uns
insgesamt sind wir fünf frauen die als
kapitäns anwärterin wir angefangen haben
eines tages wird sie selbst ein solches
schiff führen davon ist sie überzeugt
und mittlerweile glaubt auch ihr kapitän
daran dass sie das tatsächlich schaffen
kann
ich sehe dass ich bei dilara ganz klar
wird sie es schaffen oder nicht klar
warum sollte sie es auch nicht können
heutzutage arbeiten frauen in allen
bereichen es gibt keinen job hin frauen
nicht auch machen können
seit einem jahr durchläuft die lahrer
alle leer stationen auf den
verschiedenen schiffstypen der
städtischen fähren
si muss sech schrubben schiffs wände
streichen lernt alles über aufbau und
wartung der maschinen
[Musik]
dieses schiff ist 40 jahre alt älter als
die anderen und diese alten schiffe
haben noch manuelle systems ist die muss
man zuerst kennenlernen damit beginnt
die arbeit auf sie sie musste es den
männern auf dem schiff beweisen dass sie
es kann sich an der bordwand abzuseilen
24 stunden schichten zu schieben
sie musste zeigen dass sie körperlich
mithalten kann auch meine freunde
glaubten erst nicht dass ich das schaffe
sagt die lager normalerweise laufen in
der schifffahrtsindustrie alle vor
frauen davon
sie sagen frauen bringen und so was zum
beispiel habe ich mich nach meinem
abschluss bei allen unternehmen von a
bis z beworben um eine praktikumsstelle
zu bekommen ich habe drei vier monate
gebraucht um auf einem handelsschiff
angeheuert zu werden und auch dort gab
es zuerst vorurteile gegen frauen
sie sagten dass frauen auf see pech
bringen aber als ich den job eine zeit
lang gemacht hatte haben sich alle dort
daran gewöhnt und nach abschluss der
ausbildung wird man dann dritter kapitän
[Musik]
manchmal kommen passagiere und klopfen
mir auf die schulter sagt dilara weil
sie wissen was es heißt sich als frau zu
behaupten in der männerdominierten
seefahrt in der türkei
ich denke dass die vorurteile irgendwann
überwunden werden
wir bereiten den weg für die weiblichen
seeleute die nach uns weitermachen
die werden dann hoffentlich nicht mehr
solche vorurteile erleben müssen
[Musik]
julia hagen kämpft gegen solche
vorurteile mit den mitteln der politik
gelungen ist parlaments abgeordnete der
prokurdischen hdp für istanbul dass
frauen nun auch in die letzten
männerberufe vordringen sei höchste zeit
meint sie von wahrer gleichberechtigung
aber seien die frauen in der türkei noch
immer weit entfernt
studentinnen junge frauen die haben sehr
ernsthafte probleme in diesem land haben
wieder steigt nach wie vor ein system
dass frauen in vielen bereichen
diskriminiert
dazu gehört auch der bereich der bildung
wir haben immer noch sehr viele probleme
was frauenrechte angeht ist die türkei
in der islamischen welt dennoch eines
der liberalsten länder moderne frauen
nehmen hohe positionen in gesellschaft
und wirtschaft ein
ob bei scheidung sorge oder
abtreibungsrecht gibt es hier oft
liberalere gesetze als in manchem
westeuropäischen land doch seit der
machtübernahme von präsident erdogan
islamisch-konservative partei main zu
labil um versuche die regierung wieder
ein traditionelles frauenbild zu
propagieren
mit dem ersatzstoff sie versuchen zum
beispiel frauen zu ermutigen viele
kinder zu haben
sie versuchen frauen auf den häuslichen
bereich zu beschränken
es ist ein aspekt dieses neuen
autoritären regimes dass es versucht das
modell einer frau zu erschaffen
die schweigt und ihre rechte nicht
verteidigt
rückblick nach der gründung der modernen
türkei durch mustafa kemal atatürk 1923
bekommen frauen sieben jahre später das
wahlrecht dürfen wählen und gewählt
werden seit 1930 also dürfen sie auch
politische ämter bekleiden später
schafft es mit tanz und schüler
tatsächlich eine frau nach ganz oben
von 1993 bis 96 ist sie
ministerpräsidentin lange bevor in
deutschland angela merkel an die macht
kommt doch eine frau an der
regierungsspitze macht noch keine
frauenfreundliche politik viele frauen
kritisieren das tanzen schüler während
ihrer regierungszeit nicht anders als
ein mann regiert habe aber tatsächlich
ein beispiel für einen maskulinen
politik stil wenn sie ihr verständnis
von politik betrachten dann ist das eine
kriegerische politik eine
antidemokratische ja eine diktatorische
tatsächlich können wir nicht über vor 30
jahren gründete die rechtsanwältin cinar
in die organisation mord schattig das
lila dach die erste frauen rechts
stiftung in der türkei auch sie die
regierung von tanz schiller nicht für
einen wendepunkt hin zu einer
frauenfreundliche politik schiller hin
oder her das macht keinen unterschied
natürlich wünscht man sich eine
präsidentin oder einen präsidenten die
unparteiisch sind sie sich der probleme
der frauen bewusst sind und auch mit der
notwendigen sensibilität in diesem
bereich vorgehen
aber ich denke dass die türkei da noch
einen langen weg vor sich hat denn die
akp hat letztendlich dafür gesorgt dass
die patriarchalischen strukturen die es
sowieso bereits gab noch weiter
verfestigt wurden
die partei für gerechtigkeit und
aufschwung akp wird von männern
dominiert frauen sind an der
parteispitze und regierung kaum
vertreten
trotzdem rühmt sich präsident erdogan
dass er frauen in der türkei erst zu
ihrem recht verholfen habe in einem
laizistischen staat der gläubige
musliminnen jahrzehntelang benachteiligt
habe eine veraltete mentalität war unter
dem vorwand der modernität
verantwortlich dafür dass unsere mädchen
wenn sie kopftuch trugen jahre lang
nicht in die schule gehen durften
das kopftuchverbot verhinderte dass sie
im öffentlichen dienst arbeiten konnten
sie wurden auch in der privatwirtschaft
diskriminiert sogar auf der straße
wurden sie angefeindet wir haben diese
mentalität gebrochen und eine brandneue
ära im leben unserer frauen eingeleitet
natürlich dürften frauen wegen ihres
kopftuchs nicht diskriminiert werden
mainzer narren alle frauen sollten
gleiche rechte haben doch wenn erdogan
behaupte frauen seien unter seiner
regierung aufgestiegen sei das falsch
das ist nur show nichts anderes es ist
eine doppelmoral er hat die frauen bei
den wahlen für sich genutzt und dann hat
er sie wie eine ausgepresste zitrone
einfach weggeworfen
die frauen in der akp selbst wenn sie
einige vorzeigefrauen in positionen
gesetzt haben dann nicht weil sie frauen
sind sondern weil sie kopftuch tragen
und propaganda für den islam machen
es ging nicht darum frauenrechte zu
verteidigen im gegenteil versuche die
parteiführung hart erkämpfte rechte
schrittweise wieder einzusammeln
jeden tag werden drei frauen getötet und
es gibt so etwas wie eine legitimierung
für frauenmorde heirat vor der
volljährigkeit wird von der regierung
unterstützt zwar wurde dafür kein
bestehendes gesetz geändert
aber auch ohne eine änderung wird
versucht die bestehenden gesetze im
sinne der scharia auszulegen so muss ich
es wohl ausdrücken
deshalb halte ich die situation der
frauen in der türkei heutzutage für
nicht wirklich gut
in istanbul trat vor zwei jahren ekrem
imamura an um die situation der frauen
zu verbessern imamura kandidat der
oppositionellen chp im kampf um das
bürgermeisteramt von istanbul
wir wollen für die frauen eine besondere
frauen politik machen
wir wollen eine gleichberechtigte
frauenfreundliche stadt werden dafür
werde ich kämpfen
nach seiner wahl setzte er ein
förderprogramm durch das ermöglicht es
auch diesen frauen zu zeigen was sie
draufhaben beim aufnahmetest für die
beamtenlaufbahn bei der städtischen
feuerwehr
es ist ein harter test und viele werden
ihn nicht bestehen eine der
bewerberinnen ist die 25-jährige dilara
karabulut
ich habe jahrelang auf diesen job
gemacht hat und in diesem jahr habe ich
endlich die chance dafür bekommen dank
meiner freunde und meiner lehrer die
immer hinter mir gestanden und dank
aller leute in der stadt
der bürgermeister hat uns in istanbul
eine chance gegeben
deswegen haben wir heute diese
möglichkeit sie finden sich für den
traumjob auf dem parcours geht es um
kraft geschicklichkeit und ausdauer
was viele der frauen auch in diesem
beruf antreibt ist der wunsch anderen zu
helfen
welche person werden wir heute rennen
können so wird es ein feuer geben und
wie werden wir es löschen
welcher bruder von mir welcher
feuerwehrmann wird sich selbst in gefahr
bringen
dieser job ist mein traum und ich mache
jeden morgen voller energie
die türkei ist ein muslimisches land in
konservativen islamischen kreisen gilt
die frau oft noch als besitz des mannes
kein anderer darf sie anfassen wenn sich
die bislang männlich dominierte
feuerwehr nun für frauen öffnet dann
auch aus sehr pragmatischen auch
religiösen gründen
manchmal werde ich gefragt ob kleine und
zierliche menschen für die aufgabe bei
der feuerwehr geeignet sind
es ist aber so dass bei vielen erdbeben
und die kleineren muss sicheren helfer
bei den such und rettungsarbeiten unter
den trümmern erfolgreicher waren
das ist die wahrheit und bei einem
erdbeben oder einem brand sind unter den
opfern auch immer viele frauen die
gerettet werden
ich denke in diesen fällen wäre es
besser wenn ihnen dann auch eine frau
aus unserem team erste hilfe leistet das
würde die qualität unserer arbeit
verbessern
250 von über 1000 bewerberinnen wurden
zur aufnahmeprüfung eingeladen unter den
strengen augen der männlichen prüfer nur
39 haben es geschafft die lara ist eine
von ihnen wird eine der ersten
feuerwehrfrauen von istanbul werden
[Musik]
auch dieses bild ist neu in der türkei
eine frau die busse durch den
chaotischen verkehr lenkt doch all dies
lande kennt sich aus mit großen autos
ist im familienbetrieb sogar lkw
gefahren
wir frauen fahren anders sagt sie wenn
eine mutter mit einem kind einsteigt
warte ich bis sie an ihrem sitzplatz ist
ich habe diese situationen selbst sehr
oft erlebt viele männliche fahrer achten
nicht darauf fahren ruckartig los sobald
jemand sein ticket entfernt hat ich
denke wir frauen fahren einfach
sensibler als männliche kunden wenzel
hinterm steuer sitzt fühlen sich die
fahrgäste bei ihr offenbar gut
aufgehoben
busfahren wird aus irgendeinem grund
immer als männlicher beruf angesehen ich
habe das nie verstanden zum glück hat
man jetzt ein schritt in die richtige
richtung gemacht
ich bin positiv überrascht ich denke es
ist richtig frauen kann jederzeit und
überall arbeiten
ich finde das sehr gut die frauen fahren
sehr ordentlich und besonders vorsichtig
sie sind sehr ruhig und im vergleich zu
vielen männern fahren sie den bus
hervorragend man fühlt sich sicherer
wenn man eine fahrerin am steuer tätig
außerdem kann ich mit ihnen viel besser
reden weil sie meine
geschlechtsgenossinnen sind heute lenken
26 frauen öffentliche busse durch die
millionen metropole istanbul 26 von
insgesamt 5344 fahren
es ist ein anfang ein neues kapitel dass
die öffentlichen verkehrsbetriebe vor
neue herausforderungen stellt die
fahrerinnen und fahrer die für uns
arbeiten
die kommen bereits in ihrer uniform zum
dienst ein problem mit einem eigenen und
carte bereich gibt es also nicht
es könnte aber ein problem in bezug auf
gesonderte damen toiletten geben
bisher gab es hier ja fast nur männliche
mitarbeiter
wir haben nur unter uns gearbeitet und
wenn männer unter sich sind dann kann es
schon mal etwas grober ziehen
aber seit die frauen dabei sind hat sich
das geändert es ist etwas
disziplinierter geworden
all dies lande ist 38 jahre alt und
mutter von zwei kindern ehemann kahn ist
ingenieur die familie gehört zum mister
mittelstand für einzel und ihren mann
ist es normal dass auch die frau
arbeiten geht für die generation ihrer
eltern aber war das nicht
selbstverständlich
in meiner jugend gab es kaum
berufstätige frauen als ich damals in
meinem job anfing kam ich abends nach
hause und mein vater empfing mich weinen
ich sagte papa warum weinst du
er sagte du wirst die erste frau in der
familie die arbeitet ich sagte aber klar
papa ich bin noch nicht umsonst in die
schule gegangen
seitdem hat sich einiges verändert in
der türkei und dann auch wieder nicht
ehe man kann erzählt von den reaktionen
in seinem ingenieurbüro wenn ich sage
dass meine frau busfahrerin ist dann
fragen mich viele wie kann sie so was
machen die sind immer noch total
überrascht
besonders in meinem eigenen
arbeitsumfeld ich arbeite mit vielen
frauen in einem team
wenn meine arbeitskolleginnen erfahren
dass meine frau bus fährt dann rufen sie
sofort an und gratulieren hier ist dass
seine mutter die ein bus fährt alle
meine freunde sagen unsere mütter
könnten das nicht
eisel zeigt stolz die fanpost passagiere
die der busgesellschaft schrieben die
sich bedanken
sie bekam eine belobigung des
managements und wird bald befördert darf
dann ist das große schnell busse fahren
ich hoffe es geht so weit dass frauen
immer und überall zu sehen sein werden
nicht nur als busfahrerin sondern auch
als kapitän als piloten
ich hoffe wir werden überall frauen
sehen in allen bereichen die auch heute
noch als männer jobs betrachtet werden
das wäre ein fortschritt für istanbul
für die türkei und für die ganze welt
drei frauen die pionierarbeit leisten
die sich in die letzten männerbastionen
wagen
doch noch immer gibt es viel zu tun ist
es für die frauen ein weiter weg zur
gleichberechtigung in einem muslimischen
land wie der türkei
[Musik]